you know one great quote as always is it
are you seeing unrest and protesting and
looting where you live I'm saying it
because I'm just glued to Twitter and me
too
you know I'm just scrolling and I can't
believe my eyes and it is it so sad
there's so many different things going
on at the same time and then the the
shitty part about that to me is that
everybody pulls a different meaning away
from it so like if you're bias going in
is you know you know if you're a racist
in one way you're going to look at this
and say oh man they're rooting and
they're looting and rioting and this is
awful what are those small business
owners do why are they where are they
getting their store smashed and then if
you're somebody else and you're looking
at this you're like dude people are sick
of it they've hit their breaking point
because this has been going on for so
long this police brutality and I totally
understand what's going on and then
other people are looking at it and
they're sort of like hey what's like why
are these other malicious groups kind of
hijacking the movement and just inciting
violence and you know antifa or some
people believe you know russia china
whoever it is who's dropping these
pallets of bricks off trying to bait
people into violence and you know some
people just trying to make the world
burn and so there's all these things
mixed together and I think whoever you
are you're gonna select the evidence
that supports your feeling and you're
just gonna get stronger you're just
gonna see more evidence towards your
view and it's gonna make people more
divided
my friend shared something and it was
like four circles and it was like I'm
pissed off about the racism in our
countries and black lives matter black
lives matters has a point I'm pissed off
that businesses are getting brewing this
is not the right way to do it I'm pissed
off as the police because I think most
of them are good but a few bad cops ruin
[__] for everyone and then I forget the
fourth one and then it was like at the
center all the circles had a little bit
of everything and like you can be here I
was like that's how I feel I'm angry it
it's sad and so what was the fourth what
support circle I don't know what the
fourth one was let's see it was really
great though did you happen to see this
go ahead and see that but no that
explains like exact
see how I feel you know and how many
people feel and you know I think it's
really crazy you know there's a whole
bunch of things that you hear you learn
from these experiences where you're like
oh you know that is a sort of a nugget
of wisdom or a bit of empathy that I
didn't have before and so you know when
you see people that are you know one
great quote I saw was when you have a
thousand good cops and ten bad cops but
the good cops don't police the bad cops
then have a thousands and then ten bad
cops and you know I believe that and
then that sort of applies to my life too
like in what anytime I sort of stand by
and do nothing well injustice is
happening that makes me sort of
complicit in my own way right and you
know I think about little minor examples
of that in my own life and then it was
George Floyd's George George Floyd's
death was murder and the police should
be held responsible I think most cops
are good but police departments are
corrupt and there are some bad cops
looting businesses and destroying
properties in morale it hurts - cause I
empathize and I agree with black five
matter protester and believe in then the
right to be heard and then right in the
middle was like I am here and this is
sad right yeah it's really crazy and I
know people don't listen this podcast to
hear like you know talks about
socio-economic issues and racism and
whatnot but you know this I think
affects everybody is very different than
anything that's happened in in my
lifetime where you have riots breaking
out across the nation all simultaneously
and things really do feel like they get
a breaking point for many reasons I
think also the fact that people were
picked up at home for the last three
months I don't think that helps
necessarily because that's a sort of a
bunch of a bunch of you know just water
boiling over you know at a certain point
as well I agree I saw I agree I don't
even love discussing this stuff
presents' think about it a lot and I
also tend to like they talk about the
positive but let me bring something up
that I don't think I have bring up
brought up and I want to hear your
opinion so I don't this doesn't matter
and it doesn't change I don't think it
should like validate or just not about
validate anything I say so like my
wife's black my family's black I'll have
black children and this was the first
time or half parsley black children this
was the first
time that I was at my house with Sarah
my wife and like she broke down she was
like I don't I don't know hops he's like
I don't know where I fit in on this
because she's like a successful black
woman she's a guy haven't had a lot of
racist stuff happened to me or if any
like I and it was and she's like but I
yeah it was it was it was just a total
mind [__] because I'm like [__] what am
I supposed to how am I supposed to I
don't I didn't know what to feel I
didn't I was like I don't I don't know
what to do and it was incredibly
exhausting do you you you're Indian do
you consider yourself white or not white
what definitely considered was of white
and nor does anyone who sees me thinks
I'm white but I don't know like how but
I get what you mean in the sense of like
in some ways like do you feel that
you're privileged or prejudiced against
I think that's a different way of
looking at it and like you know my
sister so we I was born in Tulsa
Oklahoma which is like you know not the
most open-minded and racially friendly
place and so my sister when she was in
kindergarten you know students would
would draw a picture of a pig and then
write her name on it and cover the body
and brown mud and then they would give
it to the teacher and the teacher
laughed and my sister who always
remembers this like she was I don't know
six years old and she vividly remembers
the teacher sort of looking at this and
laughing and saying no no no put it away
but like being you know involved in it
and I know I don't understand that
what's the pig have to do is that
because just like a brown brown dirty in
the mud you know that sort of thing and
and you know I remember you know when
she went to my mom it was like why can't
be we'd be white said the thing where's
like you know asking questions as a kid
just trying to understand why am i
different what does that mean why do
other people think were worse than them
that sort of thing I personally never
experienced that because I had luckily
moved at Oklahoma when I was really
young and went to different places where
it was it was less so or just got lucky
and sort of my experiences around who I
was around but I guess I would say like
you know when 9/11 happened you know
they're not fun to be a brown guy in are
you are you any religion a Muslim no
under and they just but I wouldn't even
do yeah I would be Hindu but you know
just that's typically what most of you
people are but yeah you know I'm not
religious but you know
I do grow a beard pretty quick and so
like yeah you know like when you go to
the airport I don't think you think
about how do I look today whereas I
think about that so I'm like look I'm
not trying to get hassled for no reason
here's let me show you before I get on
this flight or like you know I had
friends who like are Muslim who had like
key their house keys taken away from
them in TSA because it was like this is
potentially a dangerous thing and then
like this is my apartment
how does that make you feel so the fact
that you have to shave are you angry
or you wait where do you what's that
make you feel like I'm not angry about
it you know I I sort of have this
opinion that my Bible my personal
philosophy if you were gonna boil it
down to any one thing is the only thing
you have control over is your attitude
towards the present moment and so so
that's empowering and disempowering
rights disempowering because it's like
[__] I can't control anything that's
going on I can't control how other
people feel how they're gonna act I
can't control the results I'm gonna get
in my life but it's empowering it's like
the one thing I control is my attitude
towards the moment so that sort of is a
super power because then no matter what
the situation is no matter what the
moment is I can decide what my attitude
about it is going to be so for example
when something shitty happens to me
someone says something shitty or you
know I you know get that extra I sort of
hate coming to this room while I go
through TSA clearance you know the
meaning I put on that is of my choosing
and if I put the meaning of it that you
know I'm less than I'm being wronged
that doesn't help me it makes me feel
like [__] and so I just decide not to
feel that way but I know that like on
the grand scheme of things I get off
pretty light it's very different than
never feeling safe you know going for a
jog in your neighborhood or something
like that I think you know there's
levels to it and I haven't experienced
those levels where it would be very very
challenging to put a positive meaning on
what's going on yeah it's uh it's just a
confusing time because you feel so many
different emotions and some of them are
opposite and I had it like talked to the
whole company today which were small
let's say twenty or thirty people and I
was like I don't know what to say other
than if you guys like ever feel out of
place somewhere like our company we're
gonna we're gonna
make you feel safe like we'll hire all
types of people we like I wasn't sure if
that felt like weak or like like oh like
like a barely anything I was like I
don't know what I was like I don't know
how to [__] handle this other than
you're safe here but uh yeah you know I
think that's the right approach because
it's not about having the answer or the
wisdom or the most heartfelt thing and
the best speech but like I think it is
important if you're the leader to show
up as a decent human being in that
moment just say look I understand I'm
also feeling this crazy mix of emotions
I just want to do my best with this
anything you know we're gonna we're
gonna try to do our best at this I think
it goes a long way to just be a decent
person and try to be present and visible
there versus kind of shying away from it
which is what a lot of people do yeah
it's crazy and I have a feeling once I
have children my opinions gonna change a
lot like or not my opinion but my I
think I'll learn a lot yeah
like having black kids or part by kids I
think well I'll maybe I'll see something
that I didn't really see and one more
thing which you know we can cut all this
out if people tell us later hey you
shouldn't talked about this on the pot
but did you watch The Trevor Noah
thing that's on YouTube or whatever I
did not I'm typically not a fan of his I
think that a lot of times he says is the
wrong take so I I tend to avoid him but
I would watch it if you suggest it
i-i'm-i'm cuz he I don't think he's that
funny but I did watch this thing and you
know he brings up like what's going on
he's like yeah a lot of people are
looking at what's going on and saying
well this isn't right either right of
course
police should not murder citizens that's
wrong but also rioting and looting and
destroying things is also not right and
what his point was which I think made me
better understand what was going on his
point was like you got to think about
this what is society you know a society
is essentially a contract it is an
agreement amongst a group of people up
here's what's right and wrong of how
we're gonna act here's the behaviors
that are tolerated here's the babes that
are not tolerated
he goes so what you're saying is that
one side of contract you know if we're
if we go
to contract together and you're just
breaching your side of the contract
regularly and without recourse and I
just see wow this guy just keeps
breaching his side of the contract then
I also have no no desire or incentive to
uphold my side of the contract he goes
you'll see somebody that's homeless and
you know they don't go and just murder
necessarily because because they're in a
bad position they say look these are the
rules of the game I'm losing in the
current game or I have not been able to
sort of get to an advantage position in
this game but like I still respect that
we're in a game together and there are
rules of this game he goes what you're
seeing now is that a group of people you
know black people in America feel like
the contract has just been breached over
and over and over again where they're
you know unnecessary and unjust violence
against us and so now we're gonna breach
the contract - and we're gonna sort of
make it very known what it feels like
when the contract is being breached for
apparently no reason and it doesn't seem
like a positive thing and so that made
me look at you know when somebody is
either protesting whether it's
peacefully or not basically when
somebody's rioting and they're creating
a sort of unsafe environment for all
it's sort of I don't know it sort of
explained to me why somebody would
behave that way it's because if you feel
like the other parties just turned
breached the contract and then there's
no recourse then it's like I'm gonna
terminally breach the contract and and
we'll see we'll see how it feels and now
both sides feel what it's like when the
societal contract gets totally breached
I definitely feel the tension I feel it
I feel it definitely feels like like
almost like the end of the world a
little bit it's like there's it's like a
small it's like in the same way having a
new puppy is just like a small taste of
having a baby it's like that's how I
feel right now like I'm like if like the
world if like everything that I believed
in is gonna come to an end it's gonna
take a little a little like this right
you know it's there every sad story
there's also an inspiring story where
people are you know waking up the next
day and going and cleaning up the city
and people standing together and you
know I think there's a lot of really
positive things going on - and I think
that's the you know that's the silver
lining or that's the other side of the
coin here where where is progress being
made and
[Music]
[Applause]